Frank Sinatra walks into your room the
wedding night and you gave yourself to
him you give you a virginity to him was
he singing did he sing to you hey baby
I'm here but he was so old he was so
much older than you he was 50 but he was
great-looking really yeah you're into
older guys I was there yeah you're into
that whole thing that's like you looking
for your father right right exactly how
did you stay a virgin through Peyton
Place that's what I can't figure out at
the beginning of Peyton Place I just
turned 19 right it was like school right
I'd ride my horse in the morning I go to
Peyton Place did you get dressed up for
your wedding night like did you put on
the car I didn't it wasn't a wedding
night we'd been going together for like
three years when we got married right I
didn't get married till I was 21 right
so no I visited him in Palm Springs that
was it and that was it hey baby how long
did it take before did you hold out what
was it it was a funny thing because he
invited me to see a screening of his
movie uh-huh and I went and I sat with
him and we were watching the movie and I
can't remember a thing about the movie
but but that we were holding hands
uh-huh and after the movie he said will
you come back to Palm Springs with me
I'm flying back tonight on my own plane
Oh God got my pajamas and the only baby
food now you know thank you very much
and you know I'm sorry about the hand
hold
I was forward you've done it and he said
no well then come tomorrow if you're
more comfortable I'll send the plane for
you and I thought you know he's gonna
send the plane for me in the cab
incredible
so all that night I said okay you know
and that night I just couldn't sleep at
all and the next morning I couldn't
decide how many jars of cat food to
bring because if I stay for the day that
was two jars but if he thought I was
going to stay overnight then I'd have to
bring four jars
and I brought four jars it's like the
boldest thing I ever did I got there and
he showed me around the house had a
separate room for me yeah and then just
see that's the best move when she has
it's a separate room right yeah and I
said I better get a cat box cuz you know
we'd flown all the way from LA I get a
cake set up my cat box now a litter box
and and he gave me a really great kiss
Wow and that was it we do pad in your
hand you put the cat down so and then he
kissed you out of my arms is real
romantic and he put it on the floor and
I remember having the presence of mind
to step on the leash yeah because you
don't want the cat running out did the
cat watch while Frank seduced you oh I
know
you know that's weird I want that my cat
in the room when I have sex let me see
that the cat box that we met in another
room and he began kissing you and
disrobed you if you undressed you yeah
do you like it the first time seriously
well you know I was a little frog yeah
probably quick - wow I can't believe it
you know Frank offered to break Woody's
legs that's true yeah I think that's
fantastic I love you baby